Trascrizione: Julia Vitarello
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Non sono una scienziata,
non sono nemmeno un medico:
però, cinque anni fa la mia vita
ha preso una svolta
che mi ha costretto ad imparare tutto
sulle malattie genetiche rare.
Prima che vi racconti la mia storia,
voglio presentarvi mia figlia, Mila,
in questo breve video.
[Nel dicembre 2016,]
[la vita di una famiglia
è cambiata per sempre.]
[Questa è la storia di Mila]
You are my sunshine, my only sunshine,
you make me happy when skies are grey.
La nostra bimba si chiama
Mila Virginia Makovec,
ed è nata il 5 novembre 2010.
Quando ripenso a Mila appena nata,
era tutta sorrisi e salute.
A mezz’ora dalla nascita,
Mila si aggrappò al mio dito
con una forza tale
che avrei potuto quasi
sollevarla dalla culla.
Quando Mila era piccola si arrampicava,
camminava in montagna,
e correva.
[Inglese] - “Quanti anni hai,
Mila?” - “Tre e mezzo”.
Era molto attiva, amava andare in bici,
giocare nella neve, andare in slitta -
[Ma qualcosa non era
perfettamente a posto]
A un certo punto, ci siamo accorti
che Mila si ripeteva.
Diceva: “Mamma, mamma devo, mamma devo...”
e non riusciva a continuare.
Poi, verso i tre anni, abbiamo notato
che aveva cominciato
a camminare in modo strano,
con i piedi leggermente torti.
E a quattro anni, ha cominciato
a portarsi i libri vicino agli occhi.
Poi, a cinque anni,
i suoi piedi hanno cominciato
a muoversi velocemente, scalpitando,
e spesso cadeva all’indietro.
E ogni volta che si rialzava, cadeva,
si rialzava, e cadeva di nuovo.
L’abbiamo portata da molti specialisti,
che però non sono mai riusciti
a capire cosa avesse.
Il tempo è passato,
e in un solo mese è cambiato tutto.
Ci siamo accorti che Mila
aveva perso completamente la vista.
Quello che le dava tanta gioia
era giocare, leggere,
guardare la tv e giocare con suo fratello;
ma all’improvviso, non riusciva più
a fare nessuna di queste cose.
E devastante vedere una bimba
così vivace e socievole
che non riesce più a giocare
con gli altri bambini né con i giocattoli,
e che non può più vedere Elmo in tv.
Mila è nata sana,
era come tutti gli altri
bambini del Colorado.
camminava in montagna, sciava,
si arrampicava, cantava -
Però, verso i quattro anni,
ha iniziato ad avere problemi:
cadeva spesso, balbettava,
si metteva i libri
e i giochi vicino al viso.
L’ho portata in giro
a fare circa 100 visite:
da medici, da terapeuti;
ma nessuno riusciva a capire
quale fosse il problema.
Finalmente, l’ho portata
in ospedale, a sei anni:
al Pronto Soccorso,
perché  non sapevo più cosa fare.
E lì ci hanno dato la diagnosi
del Morbo di Batten,
una malattia genetica rara.
Ma era una malattia mortale.
All’inizio, devo ammettere
che ero contenta,
perché finalmente avevamo
trovato il problema.
Però, col tempo, ho letto del Batten
e mi sono resa conto
che il Batten è una delle malattie
più gravi che ci siano.
E nessun bambino è mai sopravvissuto
oltre i 10, 11, 12 anni.
In quel momento, Mila aveva sei anni.
Ho iniziato a leggere di tutto,
sulle pubblicazioni
di medicina, di scienze.
E ho iniziato a parlare
con ricercatori, con medici,
con chiunque lavorasse in questo mondo
delle malattie genetiche.
Ho parlato con altri genitori
che combattevano per i loro figli.
E mi sono resa conto che,
se io non avessi fatto niente,
non ci sarebbe stata
nessuna speranza per Mila.
E quindi ho creato una fondazione,
e ho iniziato a lavorare per una cura.
Ho raccolto fondi.
Ma poi è sorto un problema,
perché quella di Mila
è un tipo di malattia
dove c’è una mutazione
che viene dalla mamma,
e un’altra del papà.
Ma nel caso di Mila
ne hanno trovata solo una,
e nessun laboratorio riusciva
a trovare l’altra mutazione.
E quindi, coi social media
cercavo un laboratorio
per aiutarmi a trovare l’altra.
Per fortuna, ho conosciuto il dottor Yu
al Boston Children’s Hospital
che si è offerto di aiutarmi.
Per settimane, lui e tutti i suoi colleghi
hanno cercato questa
mutazione che mancava,
e finalmente l'hanno trovata.
Hanno testato anche mio figlio,
che in quel tempo aveva solo due anni.
Per fortuna, mio figlio non aveva
il Morbo di Batten.
Però ha confermato
che Mila invece aveva il Batten,
e non c’era una cura.
Non c’erano neanche quasi scienziati
che lavoravano su questa
malattia così rara.
Quando il dottor Yu
ha trovato la mutazione,
ha avuto un’idea, un'idea per una cura.
E oggi non ho il tempo
per raccontare la storia
di quello che è successo dopo quell’anno;
ma in un anno solo,
il dottor Yu e tutti i suoi colleghi
hanno sviluppato una medicina,
l'hanno testata
e dopo un anno ci siamo trasferiti
dal Colorado a Boston,
e Mila iniziato una cura nuova
che ha preso il suo nome,
Milasen.
Prima che Mila iniziasse
ad assumere Milasen,
aveva crisi epilettiche,
da 20 a 30 al giorno.
Ha perso la vista completamente,
quasi non riusciva più a camminare.
Ma dopo che ha iniziato Milasen,
abbiamo visto come la medicina
non solo fermasse la malattia,
ma c’erano miglioramenti.
Prima non si mangiava più con la bocca,
e si alimentava con un sondino;
invece, dopo il trattamento:
ha ricominciato a mangiare con la bocca;
riusciva a fare dei passi,
con il mio sostegno;
non c’erano quasi più
le crisi epilettiche.
E più di tutto, iniziava
a sorridere e ridere di nuovo.
Questo è il primo anno.
Nel secondo anno, non era molto chiaro
se la malattia si fosse stabilizzata.
Sembrava più o meno stabile.
Però, nel terzo anno,
la malattia di Mila
ha continuato a progredire.
Quest’anno, a febbraio,
lo spirito di Mila
ha lasciato il suo corpo.
E oggi,
sto cercando di vivere
in un modo diverso.
Tutto quello che abbiamo fatto per Mila
non era in tempo per lei.
Però, la sua storia ci ha fatto vedere
quello che è fattibile oggi,
cioè sviluppare
una medicina personalizzata
adatta a una singola persona.
Tradizionalmente,
le medicine vengono sviluppate
per un centinaio di migliaia di persone.
Ci vogliono dieci anni
e circa 12 miliardi di dollari.
Per le malattie rare, però,
questo approccio non è adatto,
perché i gruppi sono piccoli,
e c’è un’urgenza.
Oggi,
ci sono 300 milioni di persone
al mondo con malattie rare,
di cui la metà sono bambini.
Di questa metà,
circa 60 milioni di bambini
hanno malattie rare mortali,
o gravemente invalidanti.
60 milioni!
La popolazione dell'Italia di oggi!
Oggi ci sono 9000 malattie rare diverse,
Ed esistono cure solo
per il cinque percento di queste.
Gli esperti pensano che in totale
saranno circa 15.000,
perché vengono scoperte nuove malattie
più o meno ogni giorno.
A questo ritmo,
ci vorrebbero duemila anni
per curare tutte le malattie rare
come il Morbo di Batten.
E questo non è accettabile.
Il problema delle malattie
genetiche rare è gravissimo.
È grave come il cancro.
È grave come l'AIDS.
È grave come il CoVid.
È una situazione gravissima
per tutta la società:
non solo per le famiglie come la mia,
ma anche per l’economia.
Dove solo negli Stati Uniti,
e solamente 400 circa
di queste malattie rare,
sono costate mille miliardi di dollari.
Ieri non c'era niente da fare,
con le malattie genetiche rare:
non c’erano cure, non c’erano terapie.
Però oggi abbiamo la capacità
di diagnosticare i bambini alla nascita,
e di sviluppare le medicine
per queste malattie,
prima che inizino i sintomi.
Col Milasen, noi abbiamo dovuto
scalare l'Everest
senza le mappe,
senza le corde,
senza l’ossigeno.
Ci saranno anche altri,
che riescono a scalare questa montagna,
però quanti?
È responsabilità di tutti noi
rivoluzionare il modo di sviluppare
le medicine per
le malattie genetiche rare.
Mila ci ha fatto vedere la strada,
ci ha fatto vedere quello che è fattibile:
rendere possibile e accessibile
una medicina per una singola persona,
una medicina personalizzata.
Però ora dobbiamo scalare questo processo,
per rendere accessibili queste medicine
a chiunque ne possa beneficiare.
Ci saranno rischi:
ormai, questo fa parte della medicina.
Però dobbiamo pesarli
contro il rischio dell'inazione.
Senza la salute, non c’è una vita:
e ormai, la storia di Mila non è l’unica.
Ci sono 60 milioni di bambini,
ognuno con una famiglia,
che soffrono come ho sofferto io.
Mila ci ha regalato una strada nuova.
Ora tocca a noi
cambiare e rivoluzionare
il modo di pensare
alle medicine, e alle cure,
per le malattie genetiche rare.